good morning
morning mary morning kate and good
morning catherine
good morning everyone and mary beth
happy birthday
oh yes happy birthday do you know it was
10 years ago today that the o'brien
budget was done
and that he cleared the balcony and
there was that huge rally in front of
the state house
10 years it was because it was my
birthday so i remember it
oh i think history will repeat itself
happy birthday
i was in the balcony when he cleared it
so
thank you tom hi sharon hi
what's up okay
i just spent my morning going around
delivering those um
rental assistance cards to my neighbor
the
local stores in my neighborhoods that
that have um
more multi-housing homes and um
somebody gave them to me from the
housing authority
and it's i was just such it was such a
good feeling to be able to do that for
people
where is everybody joe how many people
are in the hall
okay let's look at the camera yeah and
then um
can you unmute all right can you hear
yes me thank you as chair of the house
finance committee i find that the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive
order 2020-04 as extended
this public body is authorized to me
electronically we have both the hybrid
meeting we're both meeting
electronically and in person please note
that there is no physical location to
observe and listen contemporaneously in
this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming
that we are a providing public access to
the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibility by
video or
other electronic means we are utilizing
zoom
video webinar for the remote parts of
the meeting and we're also here present
in reps hall
all members of the committee and the
staff of state agencies with agenda
items have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through the platform
and the public has access to the
contemporaneously watch
and or listen to the meeting on zoom or
phone
following the directions that links
provided in the house calendar
at http colon backslash backslash
g-e-n-c-o-u-r-t dot s-t-a-t-e
dot n-h dot u s slash house
slash cal jorn c-a-l-j-o-u-r-n-s
slash calendar c-a-l-e-n-d-a-r-s slash
2021 slash h
uppercase h uppercase c space
eight dot pdf
writing the public notice of the
necessary information for
accessing the meeting we previously gave
notice to the public
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting telephonically instructions
have been provided in the house calendar
provide c providing a mechanism for the
public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anybody has a problem
please email lba underscore
fiscal at leg
dot state dot nh dot us
uh dee adjourning the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence
please also note that there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law the clerk will call the role
thank you mr chairman representative
ober
i'm here in reps hall with a lovely
group of people
thank you representative berger
representative umberger is in rep's hall
representative uh turkoff for danielson
representative turcotte in rep's hall
representative representative tibbers in
reps hall representative petrie is here
in reps hall
representative emrick i'm in reps hall
[Music]
representative irf president reps hall
representative griffin
aaron repsol representative edwards
uh here in reps hall representative
doucet for bean
present repsol
president of repsol
representative lin a president in reps
hall
representative walner present in reps
representative norgren representative
nordman is in my dining room
in hanover and there's nobody in the
room
thank you president pucco
yes i'm present at my home in conway and
there's no one else in the house
president leishman good morning uh here
in reps hall
representative hatch i'm here i'm
president in reps hall with all my
friends
thank you representative rogers
i am in my apartment in concord um alone
except with my dog romeo
representative walls present
in my home here in beau and i am alone
here in this room
thank you representative heath
good morning mary heath here in my home
in manchester and i am home alone
murray good morning representative
murray is home in newcastle alone in the
in my office thank you representative
wyler
you are here i'm president of reps hall
in hall
very good mr chairman there are 21
people present we have a quorum
thank you for all appearing we will
begin
the agenda this morning by recognizing
representative lin for a motion
thank you mr chair uh mr chair i have a
motion
uh it's labeled as 2021
1056h and it deals with the subject of
closed
loop referral systems i'd like to uh
briefly speak to the motion if there's a
second
okay i'd like to second that all right
we have a motion in a second as
discussion
and representative lynn is recognized to
discuss his
amendment yes uh thank you mr chair um
yesterday um i voted against uh the
the earlier proposal that dealt with
this because
i felt that there were there were some
problems the chief wanted among
among them for me was that i thought
there was some inconsistency in the
language of the uh
of the motion in that it didn't make
clear
um whether uh
undertakings or or uh services that were
to be provided pursuant to the existing
700 000 contract but which might not yet
have been
arranged for um were to be were to be
prohibited under the earlier proposal or
not
i i think the intent was probably that
they weren't to be but it wasn't clear
to me that that
that the language would accomplish that
um
so working together with uh
representative edwards um
we came up with some some alternative
language that i think makes it clear
that the the department is entitled to
to carry out the the full terms of the
existing contract for 700 000
even if they haven't sort of committed
the funds at the point where this
amendment uh becomes law if it does
become law
um but that there's to be no further
uh contracts uh undertaken by
by uh the department until uh the
legislative oversight committee
has an opportunity to uh review
uh the particular in particular that
it's it's a comprehensive review but in
particular they're gonna be focused on
the privacy
implications of this because i think
it really is a significant concern i
think should be a significant concern to
everyone that
this is far more than simply the sharing
of medical information between medical
professionals who may be providing
services to any individual it goes well
beyond that
and in my understanding is it's not even
limited at least potentially
is not even limited to medicare or
medicaid recipients rather it could
apply
really to anyone who happens to get
uh to provide information to
a food service provider or any any other
kind of non-medical
situation um and i think that's a
an area of potential concern that really
ought to be looked at
by the legislature before this continues
so uh that's i think that's what this
amendment accomplished
thank you representative lynn are there
any questions
representative walner
now is it on yeah it is on today thank
you
um is isn't the
amendment that you've introduced today
that's before us
isn't this the subject of a bill that
was in the health and human service
committee and i
believe i haven't seen the calendar of
course but i believe it may be
on the calendar and being reported out
next week at our session so isn't this
the same
subject matter that was dealt with in
health and human services
i'm gonna i'm gonna defer to uh
representative edwards on that
um
thank you representative lynn and thank
you representative walner for the
question
uh although similar this is not
substantively the same thing as
uh house bill 601 and
and even if it were this would be an
example i think
of a belts and suspenders strategy
of making sure that something this
important does find its way into law
so redundant or not which i don't think
it is at all
it still nevertheless a good amendment
and i'll support it
representative rogers for a question
thank you mr chairman um after the other
day i
in fact went to the health and human
services
committee and pulled a file on the bill
that
this is similar to and and looked at not
only the bill but
the amendments that were there um and i
know representative edwards who
testified on the bill and talked about
it
at that hearing and this is
substantially similar
to a number of the amendments they were
voted on
and talks about the the closed system
loop referral system in the committee
they did in fact take a vote and it is
on the calendar
it was quite a large majority vote that
they um
i believe it was 17 or 14 to five
actually
the vote to itl it and the concerns were
about
they asked someone in the attorney
general's office about
constitutional questions and he
expressed some concerns
that needed to be looked at so i'm
concerned
that what we're doing is taking quote
another bite at the apple
for a bill that um while people did
share concerns they had other concerns
with
you would express that you wanted the
senate to get the house's position
it appears to me like they're getting a
position and we're going to be offering
them yet another position to look at so
if they're getting both sides of a
position it's similar to getting nothing
so again um i expressed concerns about
why we're taking what a policy committee
that
dealt with this at length took a
position on
and we're doing the bill
which again is policy and we're supposed
to look at the financial aspects of it
not the policy
especially when the committee policy
committee has looked at it
and we're doing another bite at the
apple and changing the policy that the
policy committee came up with
um i don't think that that's our place
but especially not
in the last minute when everything else
is done
without having the proper time for all
of us to consider it
um i i understand you've considered it
for quite a while
you said the other day that
representative earth had also considered
for quite a while
and both of you are very intelligent you
understand this policy well but i think
that
for the whole committee to vote on it
with a very limited time
is not the way we should be doing
business so i would suggest that we
um hold this and and let it be dealt
with by the policy
committee that will in fact have it in
the calendar
at the same session not maybe the same
session but the same group of days that
the um
health human services will have it on
the calendar i guess i don't see why
we're going to overturn everything
all right i've got a lousy speaker here
that i
can't understand most of what you say
but
was there a question representative
edwards did you understand
the question well i i understood
uh representative rogers in summary
to not agree with having
the finance committee set this as policy
when she thinks there's a
parallel path and a more appropriate
path in the
policy committee which i i think is
is not an unfair observation but i
i would just want to point out um from
my own perspective
that what ultimately what this does is
it reaffirms what the
health and human services oversight
committee can do
already which is to take a look at
activities in the department and
determine
if the department is using
it's its best efforts to achieve
efficiency and effectiveness
in their operations well what this does
a little bit
more though is it clarifies that the hhs
oversight
has a function in this case to review
and to report on whether or not
from the oversight committee's
perspective privacy rules
and regulations are being followed to
the extent that
we believe that the new hampshire
constitution on privacy
expects us to it's established a very
high
standard that uh that there's concern
that not all departments not all
legislators have fully embraced at this
point
and is worth a careful examination
thank you representative rogers did you
have further
i guess i'm just concerned that we turn
it over to the
the legislative oversight of the health
oversight committee
it's kind of like turning something over
to fiscal and we've all here
expressed concern before that we let a
small group of legislators do
what um 400 should be doing and
again i'm sorry if my speaker's not
working well but
again i think that we want to have more
legislators make decisions rather than
less
and if this is the precedent we want to
set about
doing policy what's to stop us from the
future
each bringing in a bill that we don't
like the way the policy decision
policy committees decided and bringing
it in at the last minute and say
well i like this bill they decided itl
so let's redo it in the budget
to my way of thinking thank you very
much
thank you further discussion
representative walnut
then representative hatch
thank you representative weiler um
i was wondering if i could ask the
sponsor of the amendment a question
did you give consideration to taking
this amendment to the floor
and amending 601 as it comes onto the
floor
i if you're if that's addressed to me i
did not and
to be honest with you i i have to say
candidly
i'm still sort of feeling my way around
the legislative procedure so i hadn't
i understand that i hadn't frankly
thought of that um
so this was this was suggested as a way
as a way to do this it seemed to me to
be
an appropriate way um to do this
and i guess you know one other point i
would make just in response to the
response to what uh your question
is as i think that this amendment
merely tells the department of health
and human services
don't make any further contracts
regarding regarding this other than the
one that's existing
until the legislative oversight
committee makes its
recommendations i don't read this as
saying and i don't think it does say
that once that's happened they are
prohibited from making contracts
presumably if the legislative oversight
committee says look there's all these
terrible things you really ought to make
we recommend you do this this and this
presumably assuming those
recommendations are reasonable
the department will follow them but i
suppose and i suppose if they didn't
then in the next session
we could you know enact legislation but
this doesn't say
they can't do that after the after we've
made
the the oversight committee has made its
it's recommended
recommendations so i don't know exactly
what the
rather as a reference made to some you
know the attorney general having some
constitutional question i don't quite
understand what that could be given the
way that i think this would operate
thank you representative hatch for a
question
[Music]
thank you is there any further
discussion
seeing none the question before us is
the adoption of amendment
1056h excuse me
if you're in favor you'll say yes if
you're opposed you'll say no
the clerk will call the roll to adopt
the amendment
thank you mr chairman representative
ober yes
representative umbrerger yes
representative
chircott representative turcotte yes
burris yes president petrie votes yes
representative emrick yes representative
irf
yes representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative set yes
representative lynn yes representative
walner
no representative norgren
no representative bucco
no representative leishman
no representative hatch
representative rogers no
representative walls no
representative heath heath votes no
rosanna murray votes no
and representative weiler yes
mr chairman of vote is 12-9 in favor of
the motion
and the motion is adopted we have
everybody's in the in the hall is seated
at a seat and those of you on
on zoom have gotten the packet on emails
that we will next be briefed on i will
call upon
the legislative budget assistant uh
michael caine to
brief us next mr kane
or good morning mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
michael caine i'm the legislative budget
assistant
um you've all done a great job getting
to this point i know it hasn't been easy
in the new environment
but we really do appreciate all the
effort you've put in as well as the
patients you've had
and support for our staff so i'm going
to ask mickey
who's monitoring this call the zoom um
webinar to share the general education
trust fund surplus statement
page one please
it was up there then it went away i
think that was the highway fun one
mickey was getting excited
so there we go thanks nick
um and so before you what you'll see is
uh the combined general education trust
fund surplus statement it is eight pages
i will not go through all
eight pages i know you've been through a
lot of documents uh this is the document
that we use during the process to ensure
that the house
is offering a balanced budget plan
including in this plan is all the
appropriations in the large document of
hospital one
any appropriations that are included in
house bill
2 uh as well as any revenue changes
included in house bill 2 and in addition
any estimated lapse or
the estimated lapse of unexpected
appropriations
so in total when you received the budget
back on february 11th from the governor
um the revenue picture was a little
different at the time in 21
uh the governor's first revenue west
myths assumed that uh
21 would have a large lapse about 150.5
million dollars
but that would not uh the revenues were
also going to be underplanned as well
in addition a negative balance of 54.4
million dollars was carried forward from
fy20
and so a draw on the rainy day fund
was estimated at that time by the
governor
of about 29.9 million dollars
so as you know we're currently in fiscal
year 21 and
um everything is moving we're in march
we have
three months left in the fiscal year
so it will end how it ends uh we'll
we'll continue to monitor revenue
um the house finance committee also
began
the balance beginning port of negative
407. estimated revenues
the first line the 2 billion 725.7
are the revenue estimates that were
adopted by the
house ways and means committee in march
i think right around march 18th
as you remember at the end of february
the house ways means committee
presented and passed and tabled house
resolution 11 which was their first
crack at the revenue estimates
based on further discussions with
department of revenue administration
the and based on discussions with the
governor's office and his discussions
with the agencies
the revenue estimates did increase and
so you'll remember yesterday that the
committee did adopt
or two days ago on monday the committee
did adopt um
the new revenue estimates of the 2.725.7
which is the combined general education
trust fund
both the governor and the house have a
62.5 million dollar revenue adjustment
and just to remind you what that was
is if you remember a couple budgets ago
um that there was some one-time
education aid for
free and reduced lunch and fiscal
capacity disparity aid
how that was funded is a restricted they
restricted the balance
of the education trust fund at the end
of 19 and put into a special
for lack of a better term special
account to be held aside
for funds provided to the cities and
towns or to the school districts in
fy 21 and so that is more just a
an adjustment on this statement total
revenues for the house
2.788.2 million dollars
which is over what the governor's
original estimates are but a little more
in line with
where uh revised estimates that the
government provided to the
uh committee earlier in the month
what's deducted from that is the
beginning balance obviously in 54.4 but
then the budget appropriations now the
budget appropriations on line nine
these are the state totals for the
general and education trust fund
uh that you'll find on the last page of
house bill 1 the large
700 plus page document and then
appropriation adjustments which you will
see on schedule
2 of about 76.206
million dollars and not just i won't
move over um two there but 62.5 of that
as we talked before
is relative to that one-time free and
reduced lunch and fiscal capacity
disparity aid which was offset by that
62.5 million dollars
the other uh 11 plus million dollars is
related to
your standard your statutory
appropriations your fiscal committee
appropriations
uh et cetera in addition um it's a
little higher than where the governor
came in because the division two as you
remember had proposed i think was about
1.9
uh million dollars in 1921
for kindergarten for those cities and
towns that have full day kindergarten
there was a lag
in the timing of the adm and so you can
see that's a little higher than where
the governor was
laps stayed the same 150.5 million
dollars
which is a high lapse historically but
something that the
governor's office and agencies do
believe they'll be able to make
this time around it was a hiring freeze
as you remember for almost complete year
there's also additional federal matching
funds for hhs
under the medicaid program so that this
lapse estimate
will hit 150.5 what that ends up doing
is a current year balance of about 66.47
million
uh deduct from that the 54.4 million
dollars
of the beginning balance and it's a
positive balance for a combined
general education trust fund of 12.066
and i just want to point out if mickey
if you wouldn't mind flipping to the
next page
why is there what does the general fund
look like you can see down on line
17 that although in total there is a
positive balance
in the combined general education trust
fund almost 19 million of that
is in the education trust fund and so as
a result if you look
purely at the general funds there is a
negative balance of about 7.8 million
dollars
again because of the 54 51.2 came
forward
to the general fund current year balance
of 43.3 so it does still result in a
shortfall
in this point in time of about 7.8
million dollars
based on statute if the state does have
a an operating budget deficit in the
general fund
and your estimated revenues are below
the projected
uh biennial plan then an automatic door
on the rainy day fund would occur and
basically what would happen is
department of administrative services
would come before fiscal committee and
request to draw
on that rainy day fund we are several
months away from that
this is again if everything ended today
which we know it won't there would be a
small draw of about 7.8 million dollars
on the rainy day
fund but as we continue through the
budget continue the budget throughout
the process and
may uh watch the revenues in the senate
um as well as the community conference
that number is going to change and and
then in addition we'll be paying
attention
to how our current revenues are
comparing versus plan
uh to see that that second trigger in
the rainy day fund is met that revenues
are actually under plan because that's
the only way that that automatic draw on
the rainy day fund
would occur and make you wouldn't mind
going back page one
thank you and so that's uh you'll see
right there the 7.8 million from the
randy dave hunt
balance after transfers 19896 that is
all in the education trust fund
you'll see that number carry forward on
row 1 in house finance
because the education trust fund is
non-lapsing
using the revenues from the ways it
means revised estimates
as well as revenue adjustments from the
various changes to
the bet rates the bet
thresholds uh the bpt rate reduction
that was provided and voted on on monday
in the various other revenue changes
the net revenues or the total revenues
came out to about
almost about 2.75 billion dollars
between the general and education trust
fund
deduct from that your budget
appropriations so again
general education trust fund budget
appropriations
of about 2.753 billion dollars
appropriation adjustments about 19.815
which you will see
on we won't flip to page three but you
will see
on your hard copy and online uh on page
uh sorry on page four you do begin to
see
uh where those various adjustments are
and i have separated them out by
division just so each division can
you know ensure that they were all
accounted for uh laps you'll see that
the laps
when the governor uh had proposed was 67
million dollars you'll see the house
finance moved
up to 71 and that's because of an action
taken in division three
which based on discussions with health
and human services
uh they did make a motion to increase
the statewide lapse by four million
dollars and 22
and then you can see another 6.2 million
dollars in 23.
so for 22 the current year ending
balance about 47.2
um million dollars cumulative ending
balance after adding in the
balance forward from the education trust
fund we'll bring that to 67.1
uh million dollars at the end of fiscal
year 22 based on the house's budget
proposal house finance committee's
budget proposal uh it's the first year
in the biennium
automatically carries forward any
negative part positive
automatically carries forward into the
next fiscal year so you can see
in the beginning balance on row one on
the final column
uh of 67.1 million dollars uh revenues
you can see the
the revised estimates on row four uh the
2.8
billion dollars and then total revenue
adjustments
of about 118 million and this is when a
lot of the tax changes proposed by
uh house finance will take effect uh
such as your business tax changes
and then the larger large one being your
um your credit to carry forward
uh the bet amendment that was adopted
which uh does instead of allowing
businesses to
carry forward all of their uh previously
overpaid taxes
they do want to work that down over
several
um several years the governor had
proposed a similar type of
um reduction but the house ways and
means committee had actually
adjusted that and the house finance
committee adopted that amendment
so your total revenues for general
education trust fund about 2.68
billion dollars and then your budgeted
appropriations
uh total budget appropriations of about
2.8 billion dollars
in house bill one appropriation
adjustments is a
17.9 million almost 18 million dollars
of positive adjustments
uh which offset those appropriations up
top and a majority of that has to do
with the division three action relative
to the back of budget reductions that
you remember uh discussing
on monday uh less the lapse the 98.2
million dollars again
uh that based on a division three action
that moved that six point two million
dollars above where the governor
had uh come in and so that the current
year balance of negative 32.2
offset by the positive balance of the
67.1
uh leaves a balance of 34.9 million
dollars
at the end of the biennium that is all
in the uh general fund
one thing i should have mentioned the
large revenue adjustment up top
uh of the 118 has to do with you
remember the statewide education
property tax
being reduced in 23 by 100 million so
that's a large majority of that
so what also resulted is that
um the general fund
since the education trust fund revenue
went down the general fund did have to
transfer
about 65 million dollars into the
education trust fund to keep it whole
and to ensure that those the reduction
in statewide property tax did not
impact the grants to the cities and
towns
or sorry to the school districts and so
the cumulative vending balance is all in
the general fund about 34.9
uh million dollars and uh no suspension
of the rainy day
fund statute based on statute uh any
balance remaining at the end of the
biennium
would be transferred to the rainy day
fund so that's why in this budget plan
from house finance that is presented
uh the rainy day fund balance at the end
of the next biennium is estimated
at about 142.6 million dollars
and so that was kind of a long way going
getting to that the budget is a balanced
budget plan
um in the general and education trust
fund
and we did also provide a surplus
statement
for the highway fund and efficient game
fund which also show that those two
funds
are also balanced so i can answer any
questions that anyone has
any questions from the committee for the
lba
you must have done a great job i don't
see any questions
thank you and so i will have mickey
unshare this screen
and right now we're going to go to
amendment uh 2021-1045-h
that is the large amendment on house
bill 1.
and uh i just asked if mickey if you
could share that screen it may take a
little bit to bring up because it is a
large document
okay and i won't uh i definitely won't
go over
every single one of these pages but
these are the
individual appropriations that the
divisions have worked on
since march or since february uh worked
with your agencies and your divisions to
go through
and to make all the various adjustments
they were presented by the divisions in
a detailed change sheet
all those amendments were then put into
the budget system by our analysts to
adjust the actual dollar amounts by
class line
that results in this cumulative
amendment of
one zero four five h which includes all
the appropriations and then beginning on
page 717 of the document you don't have
to scroll down mickey is the
the sections including the back of the
budget reductions the revenue estimates
uh et cetera so this uh two zero two one
one zero four five h is the uh
cumulative amendment
for house bill one uh based on the
adopted recommendations for the division
on
uh monday
and so if you um typically you'll take a
um
you'll take a roll call on 1045h and
then i will
get over to i'll move over to house bill
2 after that vote has been taken
okay we'll entertain a motion on
accepting
uh amendment one zero four five h
to hb1 second
all righty hold up your hand if you made
the motion was it representative
amberger
and representative ober's seconds
all right the other way around ober and
then mumburger
and further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call a role
on the
adoption of amendment 1045-h thank you
mr chairman
representative holber yes
representative umberger yes
representative turcotte yes
representative burris yes
president petra votes yes representative
tracy
yes i'm sorry representative emerick
jeez
brain's going to hell uh representative
irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative yes representative
lynn yes president walner
no representative norgren
representative
no sorry not a problem
there's an abuco no
representative leishman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers no
rosetta walls no
representative heath heath votes no
presenter murray no representative
weiler
yes mr chairman the
vote is 12 to 9 in the affirmative
and we have adopted hb1 amendment 10 45
h thank you
further from the lba mr king
um thank you the uh next amendment is
two zero two one one zero five zero h
uh this is the amendment to house bill
two
uh based on the actions on monday i'll
have mickey
share that screen uh with with you
in just a moment thank you
yes uh representative edwards uh thank
you mr chair
i'm just curious as we go into review of
hb2
if you could uh explain to us
how how we will be voting today and
whether or not our vote can incorporate
a representative lin's earlier amendment
uh one zero five six
h i'm just curious what the procedure
here is to get
it included since it wasn't there until
this morning
mr kane did you understand the question
yes so
the first uh the first vote you'll take
is
on 10-0-5-0-h
you've already taken a vote on
10-0-5-6-h
and then after you do take the vote on
1050h
you would take an uh motion to
ought to pass as amended by both
amendments
on house bill 2 and take a roll call on
that as well
so you'll take one roll call you've
already taken one on 1056. we'll ask you
to take one on 10.50
and then after you make that we'll ask
you to take one final roll call on house
bill 2 on
uh house bill 2 ought to pass as amended
by both 10 58
and 10 5 6 h uh what we will then do is
work with legislative services
um add basically 1056 would be added to
the end of
uh this document so the amendment number
will change and that's what will be
printed in the
calendar for all the members
thank you very much for that explanation
i understand
okay okay any anything further on
questions or discussions on
hb2
by representative ober second by
representative umberger
to adopt amendment 1050h
on hb2 is there any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
if you're in favor of adopting that
amendment you'll say
i yes if you're opposed you'll say no
clerk will call the roll
on amendment 1050h to hb2
thank you mr chairman uh rosen ober
yes representative umberger
yes representative turcotte
yes residential burris yes
representative petrie votes yes
representative emerick
yes representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes representative uh doucet
yes representative lynn
yes rosanna walner no
representative norgren no
representative bucco no
representative leishman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers
no
representative walls no
representative heath youth votes no
president murray no and representative
weiler
yes mr chairman of voters 12 9 any
affirmative
mr chairman representative ober thank
you mr chairman i move to adopt hb2 as
amended
motion by representative ober to adopt
hb2 as amended by i assume
1056 h yes sir
in 1050h 1056
h and second by representative emerick
to adopt
the motion to uh amend hb2
by that amendment 1056 h as well as
1050h
as well as 10.58 so we've already
adopted 1058 we've adopted 1056.h as a
committee
correct thank you okay okay amendment
manager
oh just
where are you uh
so this is uh oh sorry if i just made
this is um
so usually if we're in person you can do
a role um a
by hands or voice vote but since we are
uh remote everything needs a roll call
so this
final motion by representative rovers to
um
house bill 2 ought to pass as amended uh
by amendments 1050h
and 1056 h and so this will be the final
vote on house bill 2. we'll do a similar
one-on-one after this
yes members my staff
yeah on house bill one after this so i
think for this one just
for house bill 2 just ought to pass as
amended uh by 10 50
h and 10 56 h and after this vote
i'll then um we can then entertain the
motion or the committee can entertain
the motion on house
one as amended very good so this is a
motion
to add amendment 1056-h to hb2
clerk we'll call a roll is there any is
the situation clear does any
further discussion seeing none the clerk
will call the roll
to adopt amendment 1056 h into hb2
thank you mr chairman uh representative
ober yes
representative omburger yes
representative turcotte
yes representative burris yes
representative peter voces
representative emrick
yes i'm sorry
that was a yes thank you
president earth yes
president griffin yes representative
edwards
yes representative doucette
yes representative lynn yes
representative walner no representative
norgren
no rosanna bucco no
president leashman no
representative hatch no
representative rogers no
representative walls no
prisoner of heath heath votes no
representative murray no president
weiler
yes mr chairman of voters 12 9 in the
affirmative
all right we have voted to add amendment
1056 to hb2 we will now
entertain a motion to adopt hb2 as
amended
i'll entertain a motion
you know what we just did no we added an
amendment now we got a vote on it
no the motion was to amend hb2 with the
other amendment
we did that yes you should be um all set
representative
weiler um we now know that uh house bill
2 ought to pass as amended by 1050h and
1056h
and so we will um work with ols to get
that adopted so
all your motions on house bill 2 are
sufficient
it does bring one last motion on house
bill 1 because the committee has already
adopted
10-4-5-8 we would just ask that the
committee take a vote
on house bill 1 to pass as amended
so moved okay motion to pass that was
hb1
right as amended yes sorry
motion and i can see the motion from
representative over seconded by
representative
emerick or romberger take your pick and
are there any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
mr chairman who seconded that motion
i guess we'll say emory
oh i thought okay so i i had
i had uh so did you say emmerich
made the motion no over made the motion
hemorrhagic seconds
okay i'm rick7 okay thank you
all right all right this is on hb1
as amended yes
all right representative ober yes
representative umberger yes
representative
turcotte yes representative burrish
yes president petrie votes yes
it was an emmerich yes representative
irf
yes representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
president of doucet yes
representative lynn yes representative
walner
no representative organ
no thank you president bucco
no representative leishman
no representative hatch no
representative rogers no
representative walls no
president police heath votes no
representative murray no representative
weiler
yes mr chairman of the vote is 12 9
in the affirmative we have adopted hb1
as amended
any further business uh mr kane
uh no
members of the committee and mr chairman
should i ask mr kane
a question representative ober has a
question for you mr cain
mr k do we normally make a motion to
allow
lba to adjust any errata that they find
that we haven't found
and should we do that we don't need it
anymore we did receive it on monday
um and we made any technical changes to
uh usually just references or make sure
that the effective dates are all set
um right now we're just going to pass
this off to legislative services we're
not going to make any more changes than
that what have been presented to you but
thank you for asking
anything further from the committee
okay thank you all for your attendance
i guess we can adjourn without a roll
call vote from what we've done in the
past
yes the objection to a journey
we are adjourned uh i will get together
with the
uh dis with the division chairs right
after this
to discuss the briefing for next week
thank you all for coming thank